So I eluded to this earlier.
My process for
finding my weaknesses was to fail.
And I think that's really valuable
in all aspects of business and
entrepreneurship, but
particularly in the early days.
You can do the job, you can do it well
enough and you'll know soon enough what
you're not good at or it may not even be
a question of what you're not good at.
It may be a question of what you're
best at and what should be sort of
delegated or handed off to
a co-founder or early employee.
So yeah, I think for
me failure was the process.
I think it's really
important what I did.
It's kind of silly, but every Friday
at 3 PM, I had on my calendar
just sit down and just think about
what was going well and what wasn't.
And I think carving out that time to
sort of introspect and think about that.
If I had a process it was that.